[Música]
fiz o curso da PM3 e os aprendizados
eles aceleraram eh as minhas práticas e
as minhas teorias na eh no dia a dia do
trabalho. A PM3 fez um papel super
importante com o Nubank pra gente
conseguir criar o nosso processo de
associate program
productem e grandes gestores de produto.
Então a gente tá ajudando aí a formar
profissionais do mercado. É, e a PM3 é o
curso que a gente escolheu para esse
programa, então é, ele ajuda tanto a
gente a criar essa base com essas
pessoas, quanto a amadurecer o
conhecimento delas de produto para que
elas consigam ser efetivadas e como
product managers lá dentro da empresa,
rodando dentro de um time. E hoje eu
acho que a PM3 ela ajuda o meu time
exatamente providenciando esse
conhecimento já
curado através do marente do que
realmente funciona para uma pessoa de
produto conseguir chegar de maneira
objetiva no que ela precisa. Então são
as ferramentas certas pra gente poder
chegar ali no resultado o mais rápido
possível. Eu tenho um caso no meu time
de uma pessoa que já era uma liderança
de outras pessoas de produto e que
depois desse curso ela foi capaz de
entender que não era só uma questão de
gestão de backlog. mas que era muito
mais uma questão de estratégia e da
gente sempre tá questionando o nosso
time de quais são as melhores formas pra
gente poder encurtar o tempo ali do
nosso cliente para ele chegar, né, no
valor que ele precisa. Então essa
pessoa, hoje eu vejo ela em reuniões de
estratégia, eu gosto muito de usar essa
expressão, trucando o time de maneira
construtiva para que eles pensem de uma
maneira cada vez mais
estratégica. เฮ
[Música]
Boa noite. Boa noite, pessoal. uma
galera aí no YouTube já respondendo. Tem
inclusive caras rostos conhecidos aqui,
rostos conhecidos. Muito legal ver vocês
aqui nessa live. Hoje a gente vai ter um
papo super interessante com duas pessoas
incríveis e eu já vou apresentar elas
pra gente iniciar essa conversa. E a
ideia é que seja bem interativo. A ideia
é que vocês falem aqui no chat, a gente
puxe perguntas e vá trocando essa ideia.
Eh, para quem não me conhece, sou o
Marcel, sou o senhor da TM3.
E eu quero fazer uma breve introdução
sobre tudo o que tá acontecendo de A
nesses últimos meses, né, nesses últimos
anos, na verdade. Mas antes dessa
introdução, eu quero que vocês me falem
da onde vocês estão falando. Eh, sei que
tem gente aí do Brasil inteiro, às vezes
a gente pega gente de fora do Brasil
também. Então, comenta. Eu sou de São
Paulo, eu sou de Belém do Pará, mas estô
aqui em São Paulo, capital. Já moro aqui
há alguns anos. Estão me falem da onde
vocês estão
falando. Mas eu queria, ó, gente de
Curitiba, Juiz de Fora aí, ó. Legal.
Santa Maria, Diadema Santos. Boa,
bacana. Legal,
gente. Fortaleza, Rio Grande do Sul,
Jundiaí, Praia Grande. Bacana.
Dando dando continuidade aqui no
assunto, hoje a gente vai falar sobre
IA, mas a gente quer falar de uma sobre
uma ótica um pouco diferente. A gente
quer bater um papo sobre inteligência
artificial para líderes, como os líderes
vão lidar com isso no dia a
dia. Mas antes da gente entrar na parte
de liderança, eu queria trazer um
algumas provocações para vocês.
recentemente uma imagem similar a essa
aqui e viralizou na internet no Brasil,
em vários lugares no mundo, eh que era o
o basicamente
o é um esboço isso aqui, nem é uma foto
original, mas é que vazou supostamente
um código de que a Open vai implementar
lá dentro deles a opção de você comprar,
fazer um checkout lá dentro, né? É,
ainda é um rumor, mas imagina só como
isso muda o paradigma de tudo, como isso
aqui mostra que, caramba, como será o
futuro? Será que o futuro a gente vai
ter aplicativos ainda? Ou será que a
gente vai conversar tudo numa interface
única? Como é que vai ser isso tudo?
Isso já faz o que a gente precisa, como
líderes, a gente precisa começar a
pensar no médio e longo prazo de que
talvez o mundo daqui a um tempo não seja
como é hoje. E a gente tem uma camada
gigantesca de ferramentas e aqui não é
nem não é nem 10% das ferramentas que
tem
existentes integram entre si e que podem
fazer uma série de coisas surpreendentes
com tendência artificial. Então, a gente
tem esse modelinho aqui de entrada que a
gente faz o prompt, tem a saída, né, o
output disso tudo, mas a gente pode usar
diferentes modelos, a gente pode usar
diferentes banco de dados, diferentes
ferramentas. Isso é só a ponta do
iceberg, de tudo que a gente tá vendo e
que ainda vai acelerar e mudar ainda
mais.
E aí eu é isso que eu quero que você
comece a pensar, o que que você como
líder tá fazendo hoje para melhorar sua
equipe, para você se aperfeiçoar, enfim,
é tantas coisas que a gente pode começar
a pensar a partir
daqui. E eu queria trazer esse dado eh
que acho que corrobora muito com esse
questionamento, que
é tem 88% dos líderes, de acordo com
essa pesquisa aqui do World Change
Reports, 88% dizem que estão acelerando
a adoção de A e que isso é um tema
importante no ano. As pesquisas de
janeiro desse ano, então relativamente
recente, isso mostra como o tema é
relevante.
E é um dos temas que a gente vai
conversar já já com nossos convidados.
Como fazer isso, como acelerar essa
adoção. Não é simplesmente dar uma da
assinatura da Gemini ou de qualquer
outra ferramenta de a pro time kit podem
usar. Não é só isso. O que mais pode ser
feito é o tipo de coisa que a gente vai
discutir hoje. Tem esse outro dado da
McKinsen, que é uma pesquisa de 2024,
mas ainda relativamente recente. Eles
falam que 72% das organizações que já já
adotaram IA em pelo menos uma função de
negócios. E de fato a gente vê IA, eu
acho que hoje em dia talvez seja até um
pouco mais, mas muitos dos casos de uso
que eu vejo ainda são razavelmente
superficiais. em sua maioria são
superficiais e a gente tem alguns muito
profundos. Inclusive, quem tiver aí no
chat também, quando a gente esver
batendo papo, conversando, vai ser legal
vocês poderem relatar eh alguns casos de
uso que vocês tenham visto na sua
empresa ou empresa de conhecidos pra
gente também debater em cima
disso. E aqui acho que isso não, esse
dado só corrobora também com a com a o
que a gente tá falando. Mostra que essa
adoção aumentou muito de 2023 para 24.
provavelmente a não tem o dado de 25
ainda, mas provavelmente tá aumentando
ainda mais para todos os outros dados
que a gente vê no
mercado. Então, de maneira geral, é
óbvio que há não é mais o futuro. Se a
gente tivesse tendo essa essa master
essa live aqui há 3 anos atrás, 4 anos
atrás, a gente ia falar: "Ah, futuro
queá". Mas não é mais o futuro, é
realmente o
agora e o breve futuro, né? O daqui a
alguns meses e daqui algumas semanas.
Então, tá na hora da gente começar a
colocar em prática muita coisa ao invés
de ficar correndo atrás. Eu faço uma
brincadeira com quem eu falo sobre isso,
que é você vai deixar o seu time olhar
de camarote o que tá acontecendo com o
IA ou você vai levar o seu time junto
para toda essa onda que tá passando?
Ele tem essa pesquisa também super
recente desse ano do World Economic
Forum que ele fala que 80% das empresas
planejam capacitar seus colaboradores
com treinamentos em a e de fato a gente
tem visto essa explosão de demanda por
todos os lados em diferentes tipos de
treinamento, em diferentes níveis de
profundidade de treinamento. Teve aqui,
por exemplo, o Yuri comentou: "Já usei
para estruturar dados de imagem e notas
fiscais". Muito legal. Tem tem coisas
assim mais complexas que acontecem,
assim como tem coisas eh um pouco mais
triviais, tem todos os níveis de
capacitação que dá para fazer e acelerar
o time
inteiro. E eu gosto muito dessa imagem
aqui para exemplificar tudo o que tá
acontecendo. Acho que ela é uma imagem
que conta essa história, apesar de
parecer um pouco complexa. Não vou
explicar para vocês o que é o duplo
diamante. Assumo que vocês já sabem,
estamos aqui num fórum para falar mais
de liderança. Então, ali em cima você
tem o duplo diamante clássico. Embaixo
aqui você tem um duplo diamante
aprimorado por IA. O que que é isso
aqui? Significa que a gente tá
expandindo tudo que a gente fazia antes
no no duplo diamante de articular o
problema, definir o problema, criar o
conceito, selecionar o conceito que a
gente vai desenvolver e testar até
chegar na solução ideal. Hoje com IADES
faz os mesmos passos, é claro, em tudo
que a gente constrói melhora de produto,
mas agora a gente consegue expandir e
fazer com muito mais velocidade, testar
muito mais coisas ao mesmo tempo. Isso
aqui também muda como a gente trabalha.
Isso aqui também muda a velocidade e os
processos que a gente sempre usou nos
últimos nas últimas décadas mudam
também. E é um outro questionamento. Seu
time não é só aprender a usar a
ferramenta de A, mas é o seu time tem
processos para usar inteligência
artificial. Ele tá preparado para
implementar os a IA dentro dos processos
que ele já tem ou até mudar os processos
atuais, porque talvez eles não sejam tão
eficientes. Isso tudo impacta sim, né, o
desenvolvimento do produto e a o
aprimoramento do produto em si.
E aí eu pergunto, eu quero que você
comece a pensar se você tá pronto para
justamente liderar essa transformação
como um um líder de pessoas e de
áreas. E antes de chamar convidados, eu
queria falar brevemente sobre a PM3 e
como isso se conecta com tudo. Eh, um um
grande objetivo da PM3 é tornar o Brasil
referência mundial em produtos e
negócios digitais. É isso que a gente,
para isso que a gente nasceu. Então,
quando a gente pensa em como fazer isso,
é óbvio que agora se torna um pilar
dessa história toda. E a gente já vem
fazendo há muitos anos essa essa
evolução da área de produto no Brasil e
a acabou se tornando uma das principais
escolas eh de produtos do Brasil. A
gente tem capacitação em tudo, em
marketing, design, em dados, em produto,
em liderança, etc. E é claro que a IA é
um pilar central em tudo isso
aqui. Ali tem treinamentos
personalizados para todo tipo de empresa
grande,
governamental, eh 10.000 funcionários de
de 100 de 100 pessoas, enfim, tem todos
os tipos gravado, ao vivo, presencial. A
gente customiza o treinamento baseado na
maturidade do seu time e isso sim é
importante dizer e baseado na soridade
de quem tá sendo capacitado também. Eu
customiza o conteúdo e com com fundo a
gente vai em cada uma dessas coisas. já
tem mais de 800, 800 empresas que já
passaram com a gente, eh, como LX, Soft
Plan, Banco do Brasil, Globo e tantas
outras que estão elevando a barra ali
dos times nessas capacitações. E de
novo, todos os tipos de capacitações
gravadas ou presenciais ou remotas
online. E a gente tem uma, a gente pode
conversar com você sobre essas
capacitações. Inclusive já dou um
spoiler aqui. A gente já vem capacitando
várias empresas com inteligência
artificial, mas sempre com a ótica de
produto, com a ótica de como você vai
melhorar o seu produto usando IA, mas
não é só ah, como você pode usar uma
ferramenta de A para escrever uma
documentação. Não é só isso. E sim como
você pode implementar IA no seu processo
de desenvolvimento de produto ou
inclusive dentro do seu produto. Como
você faz experimentos com isso? como
você realmente muda a maneira de
trabalhar e a maneira de entregar
software pro seu usuário final. Então,
se você tem interesse em capacitar a sua
equipe, em capacitar as pessoas da sua
área, você pode escanear CR code,
conversar com o nosso time. E se você
não for líder e tá aqui também de
curioso, eh, você também pode recomendar
paraa sua liderança. Olha, a PMT tá
capacitando a galera em A, uma boa
oportunidade pra gente se capacitar aqui
internamente. Tem muita coisa legal que
a gente tem feito em várias empresas e a
gente sabe o impacto que isso dá logo
depois, porque as pessoas mudam a
maneira de
trabalhar. Mas a gente vai mandar o link
aí também, tá? Então se você quiser
escanear o Kcode também tem o link no
chat.
Mas sem mais delongas, gente, eu quero
lembrar
que como um canivete suíço, a I ela abre
infinitas possibilidades, mas a gente
tem que saber usar ela e no momento
certo. Mas agora chegou a hora dessa
nossa conversa, desse nosso bate-papo e
eu queria chamar a Fernanda Faria, que é
diretora lá da EV, e a IF, tudo bem?
Tudo bom. E você?
Tudo ótimo, prazer ter você aqui. Eu
queria chamar também o Luciano
Martins, AI developer e tecl manager lá
no Google. Fala Luciano. E aí, Marcel?
Boa noite, pessoal. Boa noite, Fernanda.
Tudo bem com vocês?
Legal, gente. Eh, para começar essa
conversa e eu quero relembrar todo mundo
que tá assistindo aqui com a gente,
vocês podem mandando algumas perguntas
no chat. não vai conseguir pegar todas,
mas a gente vai interagindo com vocês. A
ideia ser bem interativa. Para
começar, eh, tanto Luciano quanto F,
muitas pessoas que eu converso, elas
ainda enxergam e a distante por muitos
motivos diferentes. Elas enxergam
distante da realidade e como elas podem
aplicar isso na empresa
delas. Vocês acham que esses líderes
têm, eles deveriam mudar esse mindset?
Vocês acham que eles vão se tornar
ultrapassados daqui a 5 anos se eles não
estarem respirando isso agora? Qual é a
percepção de vocês em relação a isso?
Boa começar
aqui.
Eh, eu acho que já estão, sei lá, essa
seria a minha resposta inicial, né? Acho
que se
você não considere a como um copiloto no
seu dia a dia, de alguma forma, você
provavelmente já tá ficando para trás.
Gosto muito de pensar na interação
humana e a inicialmente você ganha muita
produtividade em muitas coisas que são
inclusive de gestão e de liderança que
você pode utilizar e comunicados que
você pode fazer, estruturar eh
informação, análise, né? Você como
líder, putz, deixa eu analisar o
desempenho do meu time, deixa eu olhar
quais foram as avaliações de desempenho
e conseguir fazer as comparações, achar
os gaps aonde eu tenho que desenvolver,
bolar um plano e tudo mais.
Então, tem muitas coisas da liderança
que você consegue agregar muito valor
utilizando eh a AI. E tem um outro lado,
né,
que como líder você também tem um papel
muito importante no desenvolvimento das
pessoas, né? Então, como que você vai
desbloquear seu time para que seu time
também ganhe, né, essa eficiência maior?
Eu acredito muito na liderança, por
exemplo, né? Então, líderes que são
curiosos, que vão, né, buscar e que vão
achar ferramentas, vão compartilhar,
eles contagiam o time.
Então, para mim, não é sobre dominar a
IAI. Acho que dominar a EAI vai ser
praticamente impossível, mas você
conseguir ser curioso sobre o tema, né?
Você atrás, é menos sobre nossa, a
empresa vai me treinar e mais sobre
caramba, que tema legal, isso aqui vai
ser importante para mim. Deixa eu correr
atrás. Acho que essas são as pessoas que
vão ter muito mais sucesso como líderes
no futuro.
Boa, boa. Eh, eu acho que eh, eu
concordo, concordo plenamente com a
Fernanda. Eu acho que assim, eu
colocaria mais uma camada
que algumas pessoas ainda acreditam que
a IA, a o uso da IA e a adoção de IA
ainda é o que ainda é o formato que a
gente tinha antes das
LLMs, antes do surgimento do Gemini, do
Chat PT, a o uso de A era um pouco mais
restrito para as pessoas que sabiam
desenvolvê-las, sabiam eh configurá-las,
sabiam otimizá-las. Então, era uma coisa
mais de nicho dentro de TI, dentro da
matemática, dentro da
estatística. E houve uma certa
democratização com a venda do Chat GPT,
do Gemini, do Lama e de tantos outros
modelos que você tem hoje, onde você não
precisa ser especialista na construção
da IA. Você pode focar o seu tempo e a
sua experimentação e a sua inteligência
em extrair valor da IA. Então hoje você
tem dois dois eh grosseiramente falando,
né, tem vários, mas tem dois grandes
perfis de profissionais de tem
profissionais que constróem a IA, que
são os pesquisadores, são desenvolv os
engenheiros especialistas de machine
learning e tudo mais, mas hoje a grande
maioria de nós, pessoas de negócio,
pessoas técnicas, pessoas não técnicas,
são as pessoas que estão usando a IA
para algum benefício pessoal de negócio.
E talvez é esse estalo que algumas
pessoas ainda não tiveram, meio que
usando um termo meio de competição de
vendas assim, meio um fud, que você
ainda tem medo, incerteza, dúvida, será
que vai dar certo? Será que eu vou expor
os meus dados se eu der acesso pro meu
time? Eh, será que as pessoas que
trabalham para mim vão embora porque
elas vão estar mais capacitadas? Então,
acho que tem algumas camadas de
bloqueios assim que as pessoas podem
estar
enfrentando na adoção de a como uma
ferramenta de assistência ou de eh ou
como copiloto, como a Fernanda falou.
Legal. É, eu eu vejo muito isso da das
resistências mesmo. E, e, e mais
recentemente, eu também já vi
resistência do liderado, muitas vezes
falando, nossa, ele não fala, né, mas
você sente que é uma resistência do
tipo, vou perder meu emprego então
também tem também tem esse tipo de
resistência que dependendo do tamanho da
empresa e da mudança que você quer
implementar, ele acaba sendo uma
resistência ainda mais complexa e mais
dura, porque, enfim, né, as pessoas de
maneira defensiva e às vezes sem querer
reagem dessa maneira maneira e acaba
atrapalhando. Vocês já viram situações,
talvez eh não necessariamente aonde
vocês estejam trabalhando, mas vocês já
viram situações assim e e como que vocês
acham que deve ser contornado esse tipo
de resistência?
Acho
que, né, falando um pouco do momento que
eu tô no Zé Delivery, do um pouco do que
a gente tá vivendo, que a gente já
enfrentou um momento de
resistência, existe o medo das pessoas
de perderem o
emprego. Eh, isso é real. Acho que
também não acolher esse medo também é
muito ruim como
liderança, mas tem um outro lado que o
que eu tô vendo acontecer assim das
pessoas usarem é que isso tá liberando
um tempo para as pessoas fazerem outras
coisas que entregam muito mais valor que
a gente nem tinha percepção do quanto
impactava, né? Então, uma
coisa, criar um componente de design
system demorava 6 horas, agora a gente
faz em 30 minutos. Cara, o que que isso
significa? Significa que o time de
design system que conseguia fazer X
componente vai fazer muito mais, sabe?
que a gente vai ter muito mais mais
eficiência como time. Então,
eh, teve um momento de transformação
também, então teve um momento para as
pessoas perceberem do tipo, caramba,
isso não tirou meu emprego, isso só me
fez muito mais produtivo, aumentou a
minha capacidade de entrega, aumentou o
quanto eu consigo gerar de impacto no
negócio. Mas esse medo, ele vai existir.
que a gente precisa colher. A diferença
é que conforme as pessoas vão entrando
mais nesse mundo e vão tendo essa
perspectiva de tipo, caramba, eu tô
produzindo muito mais, eu tô, cara, pô,
eu consigo fazer muito mais coisa, eu
consigo impactar muito mais o negócio,
olha o resultado, olha o tipo de análise
que eu tô construindo agora versus o que
eu construía antes. Então isso também
pode trazer um outro lado das pessoas de
cara se sentirem mais seguras por conta
de utilizar as ferramentas. Então acho
que tem os dois lados assim.
É, com certeza. E e talvez assim uma
outra um outro olhar que entra na na
visão assim de acolhimento que a que a
Fernanda falou
também, tá acontecendo muita coisa no
mercado como um todo e a gente vê muitos
movimentos de empresa acontecendo que
acabam até fortalecendo um pouco esse
medo de eu vou ser substituído, eu vou
perder meu emprego. É, por exemplo, hoje
mesmo, eu não sei quantos de vocês viram
eh o o a fala do CEO do Duolingo falando
que vai acontecer um grande esforço na
Duolingo de substituir vários trabalhos
manuais puramente há o que você consegue
traduzir lendo que pessoas vão ser
demitidas ou pelo menos você assume que
isso vai acontecer, né? Não tem como
você vai como você ter certeza. Então
meio que isso fortalece o medo que as
pessoas têm, especialmente aquelas
pessoas que não são diretamente ligadas
à TI, usam a TI como acessório ou como
facilitador. E eu acho que o o papel de
todos nós comoos líderes, como líderes,
é esse da empatia, do acolhimento, de
primeiro conseguir lidar com os nossos
medos, com o nosso com o nosso bloqueio
de putz, eu vou ter que estudar do zero
outra coisa, eu vou ter que adotar isso
agora, que é um bloqueio natural que
todas as pessoas têm, independente da da
faixa etária, independente da função. e
ao mesmo tempo aí como líderes nós
conseguirmos ter o tempo e a dedicação
para reforçar para as pessoas a
importância delas no ecossistema que a
gente tá fazendo parte, seja na
construção eh do das soluções como dos
delivery, seja nos conteúdos e nas
consultorias da PM3, seja dentro do
Google, seja dentro das empresas que as
pessoas estão trabalhando aqui, nós
temos um valor humano agregado no que a
gente faz, que é que é praticamente ente
um skill adicional aos hard skills que a
gente pode ter de desenvolvimento, de
gestão de produto, de gestão de projeto.
E isso é um diferencial, isso é um
valor. Então eu acredito até alguém
alguém comentou no no no chat, eu acho
que foi o Davis que comentou, é como
lidar com esse medo. Eu acho que esse
medo, assim, é como todos os outros
medos que a gente lida na vida, a gente
tem que ter um pouco de terapia de
exposição, a gente tem que encarar um
pouco esse medo e a gente tem que buscar
ajuda, ajuda de pares que a gente tenha,
ajuda de líderes, ajuda de mentores, pra
gente conseguir entender como que a
gente lida com esse medo e como que a
gente consegue enxergar uma forma que a
ferramenta vai ajudar a gente. Não
adotar por adotar, só para dizer no no
LinkedIn e no X que você tá usando o
Maiá, mas entender, poxa, no meu
trabalho, o que que isso agrega no meu
tempo, na minha produtividade, na
qualidade do que eu gero e que realmente
vai gerar valor, porque aí essa visão do
tipo, ah, vou criar minha conta no
Google ou na Anropic, só para eu tirar
screenshot, olha que legal que eu tô
gerando com a IA. Eu acho que isso é um
pouquinho perda de tempo também.
É isso aí. É, a pessoa fala: "Ah, eu tô
fazendo foto do Gible Stú". É isso. Isso
é é muito legal se falar isso, Luciano,
porque todas as entrevistas que eu fiz
nos últimos meses, eh, eu perguntei pra
pessoa como ela tá usando no dia a dia e
para ela me contar o caso de uso e para
ela me contar um passo a passo do que
ela tem feito. É claro, a pessoa pode,
né, falar o que ela quiser, pode ser
verdade ou mentira, mas ali você
consegue já ter uma
noção da profundidade dela, se ela
realmente tá usando, ela vai trazer
profundidade. pode até perguntar: "Ah,
mas nesse caso aqui não dá problema, o
que que você que você faz?"
Então é o tipo de coisa que seja você um
líder, fica minha dica para você
entender mais do assunto, para conseguir
cavar esse tipo de coisa na entrevista.
E se você é um liderado, pensar que é
importante você superar esse medo
justamente por causa disso. Vai se
tornar algo basal em processo seletivo.
Vai se tornar eh o se já não se tornou,
eu diria aqui, vai se tornar cada vez
mais. E aproveitar esse gancho de
de execução, né, de tarefa, eu queria
perguntar para vocês o que que mudou no
dia a dia de vocês como
líderes o uso da IA. Talvez detalhar um
pouco mais, acho que a Falou bem no
começo, mas detalhar um pouco mais. Eh,
isso ajudou na forma de tomar decisão?
Se sim, como é que você agora toma a
decisão com a IA? Eh, enfim, eh, queria
ouvir um pouco de vocês, de Cus
mesmo. Lá, Luciano. Boa. Valeu,
Fernanda. Eh, eu acho que segue nessa
linha assim da gente tentar enxergar o
que que a gente gasta mais tempo fazendo
para conseguir um resultado e como que a
gente pode eh como que a gente pode
adotar alguma inteligência artificial
para tentar pelo menos acelerar esse
processo. Por exemplo, assim, um exemplo
super prático. Eu trabalho num time que
desenvolve as novas versões do Gemini na
nas APIs, na Google Cloud, no IA Studio,
nas diferentes superfícies que que o
Google oferece.
Eh, um problema um desafio que nós temos
assim que é comum literalmente para
todas para todas as empresas que têm
soluções utilizadas por usuários finais
ou por usuários externos, eh como que
você captura feedback de uma forma
construtiva e que vire melhorias de fato
pro produto. É isso. Isso eh existem
abordagens que você pode ter, existem e
experiências que você traz de outros do
do passado, de outros produtos, mas na
prática não tem uma resposta eficiente
final. O que que a IAM me ajuda nisso?
por exemplo, eh, um local que você acaba
tendo muito feedback de produto. Eu
imagino se isso vha para para Fernanda,
isso vale pros colegas que trabalham no
Uber, eh, na plataforma do Uber e valem
pra gente, vale pra gente também. são as
plataformas sociais, Reddit, eh, um
pouco ainda Stack Overflow, X, mas, eh,
normalmente ou você tem um time de
marketing que se dedica a isso, mas
conhece da plataforma, mas não conhece
do produto, ou as pessoas de produto
tentam fazer um best effort de gastar um
tempo nas plataformas e ficam pensando
alguns alguns comentários, aqueles que
tm mais retweet, aqueles que tm mais
comentário. E o que me ajudou foi tentar
criar alguns mecanismos internos usando
LLM, usando as APIs das plataformas para
eu conseguir criar um canal de captura,
de feedback em geral. Mencionou de Minai
e eu quero. Mencionou de Minai, pode
estar falando do signo, pode estar
falando do filme, pode estar falando do,
pode estar falando bem, pode estar
falando mal. Eu quero essa informação.
Aí isso me gera alguns milhares de
comentários e de postagens diárias e que
se eu fosse fazer na mão eu tava
ferrado. Se eu fosse botar numa planilha
ou alguma coisa assim, eu tava ferrado.
Aí eu tenho o meu o meu aplicativozinho
do Gemini que eu uso para fazer a
classificação desse conteúdo. O que que
é feedback de melhoria no produto? O que
que é um xingamento porque a pessoa tá
infeliz mesmo? O que que é um elogio? Se
é um elogio, o que que tá sendo
elogiado? Então isso me deu uma visão de
uso, uma visão de experiência do usuário
que tá me valendo mais se eu tivesse
comprado dados de CRM ou alguma coisa
assim, porque é o tempo real e é o
feedback assim mais bruto no sentido
assim mais eh mais honesto e mais direto
que eu posso conseguir, entendeu? Então
isso para mim foi um uma mudança absurda
de dia a dia.
Realmente isso daí desbloqueia
muitos muitas abas paralelas na cabeça,
né? Quando você junta um monte de
informação
e deixa ser faz você rever inclusive
alguns pontos de prioridade no roadmap.
Eh, e é muito bom para classificar assim
a a facilidade de condensar as
informações, classificar, agrupar,
trazer as coisas mais relevantes. Cara,
isso é sensacional. E muito do que a
análise, a sua capacidade de análise,
ela meio que multiplica eh quando você
consegue usar, né?
E o que eu gosto de usar, tá? Eu gosto
de usar, eu do notebook LLM para pegar
textos e artigos e coisas que eu acho
densas e transformar num podcast, que eu
aprendo melhor escutando, então tenho
uma facilidade eh para aprender
escutando. Então, para mim é muito bom
nesse momento. Eh, eu uso
muito, eu criei os meus GPTs, que eles
têm capacidades específicas lá. Então,
tem inclusive um que chama VP de
produto, eh, que tem uma série de
informações, ele, né, me ajuda muito a
tomar decisão. Ele tem mais memória do
que eu, inclusive, para guardar as
coisas.
Eh, no time em geral, né? O que que eu
tenho visto assim?
que tem me ajudado a gestão do time no
dia a dia. Eh, muita coisa de avaliação
de desempenho, consegui consolidar tudo
que eu fiz, me ajudar a criar planos de
desenvolvimento, rotinas, eh uma série
de coisas. Então isso ajuda muito. A
gente fez um, foi eu e algumas pessoas,
né, do Zé fazer um curso no MIT sobre
Ei, mais voltado para negócio até e eles
têm um negócio chamado algorithmic
business thinking. São algoritmos que
são que ajudam você a estruturar a
solução de problemas de negócio, né? E
aí a gente usou para montar a estratégia
de AI que eh que a gente queria paraa
empresa, né? Então, de utilização de AI,
expansão, não sei quê, porque a gente
tinha gasto uns dois meses fazendo
aquilo. A gente subiu as perguntas, o
algoritmo em 5 minutos tinha basicamente
a mesma estratégia que a gente tinha
gasto dois meses fazendo. Então assim,
eh, tem um um ganho ali de inclusive
fazendo perguntas que a gente não tinha
não tinha pensado sobre isso, ajudando a
gente estruturar plano de comunicação e
tudo mais. Então, se você consegue
evoluir na sua habilidade de
prompting, tem muita coisa que melhora,
assim, que é uma capability que era
muito mais do time de engenharia, né, e
que eu vejo que tá cada vez mais
difundindo entre outros times.
Muito legal, F. Depois você podia
compartilhar esse framework aí depois
com a gente, então seria muito legal.
Eh, e, e, e é bem interessante, você
contou, eh, eu vou citar aqui brevemente
algumas coisas que eu faço também,
mas eu discuto com a minha chat GPT
coisas que a gente pode fazer na
PM3 e é claro, eu não vou
necessariamente acatar ou simplesmente o
que ela cata. Eu
discuto e para expandir minha maneira de
pensar, expandir minha afetividade,
expandir as opções, né? Eu diria que é
muito mais isso do que simplesmente
adotar uma resposta que foi dada. E acho
que isso isso já muda a maneira que a
gente trabalha de certa
forma. Tem tem outras coisas que eu eu
testei recente com LLM que era eu pegar
uma página que já existe nossa,
inclusive da PM3, falar: "Olha, a gente
criou essa página, aliás, eu nem falei,
falei: "Analise essa página secou
assim". analisou a página, eu falei: "Tá
bom, agora eu vou te agora analisa essa
página do ponto de vista de marketing."
Aí ela analisou e eu acertou cravado
assim, tipo, o motivo pelo qual aquela
página foi criada. Falei: "Cacete, muito
legal". Eu falei: "Perfeito, agora que
você entendeu
isso, eu quero que você me diga como eu
posso criar mais páginas assim para
esses outros públicos." E a ela faz um
negócio aqui, que a gente já levou, a
gente vai ter que fazer um discovery de
semanas ou meses para pensar em todos
aqueles públicos, porque eram personas
tão diferentes. É claro que
provavelmente ela tem alguns erros ali,
independente do LM que a gente usa, ela
tá, né, conjecturando de certa forma,
mas você dá um salto eh nas suposições
que você iria criar, que você tá estaria
fazendo descover de entrevistas com
usuário, você já dá um salto, você já
chega no descovery de maneira mais
assertiva, não elimina a etapa do
descovery, mas você deixa ele mais
assertivo. Isso já muda muito a maneira
de fazer produto assim, de maneira
brutal mesmo que e eu tô falando da
etapa que era manual, da etapa que nem
código, da etapa manual mesmo que a
gente tinha de, né, de entrevista com
usuário, depois a quali quali a quant,
depois do protótipo etc. Você consegue
acelerar muito isso.
E sabe uma coisa legal que a gente
começou a fazer eh foi criar usuários
sintéticos, né? que um dos maiores
problemas que a gente tem no final das
contas, quando você tá na etapa de
descobre e validação, é entrevistar o
usuário. Sempre é custoso, né? Então,
putz, demora tempo, você tem que, né,
recrutar as pessoas, etc. E aí a gente
tem uma uma que a gente chama de rota do
consumidor. Então, toda sexta-feira a
gente entrevista duas pessoas paraa
empresa inteira ver. Então, tem um
repositório razoável eh de entrevistas e
de outras entrevistas que a gente já
fez. E aí uma um designer do time
inclusive resolveu pegar isso, colocar e
mexeu lá em um monte de coisa e no final
começou a criar usuários sintéticos e a
gente foi testando as perguntas que a
gente fazia paraas pessoas nessa
sexta-feira que tem entrevista, a gente
perguntava também pros usuários
sintéticos e aí começou a dar 90% de
compatibilidade. E aí agora a ideia é
usar esses usuários sintéticos para
julgarem as soluções que a gente tá tá
fazendo para ver o que que faz sentido.
E outra coisa que a gente fez é com tudo
isso de informação foi criar
um analisador do tipo, ah, mais técnico
do da UI que você tá criando, né? Então,
putz, essa hierarquia tá boa, não tá,
que a leitura tal. Então, considerando
público e algumas limitações, então você
ganha um um mundo novo de tool kit para
produto design também. Animal. Muito
legal esse case. Muito legal. Eu já vi
eu já vi umas ferramentas de uso
sintético, mas que era sintético que
você não usava a base, né? Tá da
empresa. É muito legal. Casos assim como
esse. Bem legal mesmo. E e a mais legal
é que foi tudo orgânico, né?
falou vai fazer o próprio time que tinha
os problemas começou a resolver os
problemas.
Nossa, maneiro, maneiro. E, e é
interessante assim que até a gente volta
pr, pra questão assim do medo das
pessoas, que eh quando eu comecei a
trabalhar com TI lá em Belém, assim, aí
vocês veem que a minha barba, a tinta tá
falhando já, então faz um tempinho, eh
eu peguei o final da era da análise
estruturada e começo da era de adoção de
eh análise orientada objeto, o boom do
do Rup, da rational e tudo mais. E
depois a gente passou pelas arquiteturas
orientadas ao serviço e foi evoluindo
nessa jornada de de adoções.
O que tem comum em todas essas jornadas
e algo que vale hoje pro mundo de
também, que até vai muito na linha do
que você tava falando, Marcel, de
validação e e do exercício que você
falou também, Fernanda, de você ter o o
os gêmeos digitais de clientes, mas
ainda tá fazendo uma entrevista com com
cliente de verdade, é que ainda o
diferencial que a gente tem de uma
pessoa e eu vi alguém comentando no chat
que assim, um dos problemas que tá tendo
na empresa que deram acesso para todas
as pessoas
E as pessoas estão assumindo que o que a
fala tá certo, empurra paraa frente,
gera mais problemas do que cria
soluções. E o diferencial que a gente
continua tendo como profissionais é o
conhecimento do negócio. continua sendo
um diferencial absurdo assim você
entender qual que é a jornada do usuário
do do Z quando tá no aplicativo, qual
que é o qual que é o hábito das
personas, qual que é o o o a variação
que tem diferentes time series durante o
final de semana, durante as férias,
diferentes estações do ano. Eh, e isso
isso não tem IA, pelo menos hoje que
substitua. Você pode ter, como você
falou que a IA cria diversas personas,
diversos cenários, mas usando o termo
que você falou, IA tá conjecturando.
Ainda é uma geração de um tipo de
conteúdo especializado. Não é algo que
você pega, encachota e bota na sua
prateleira ou aplica no seu processo.
Então esse valor de decisão humana ainda
é ainda é primordial.
Perfeito. Então, e e eu acho que é
justamente isso, a gente conseguir
conectar com o nosso contexto. E aí, já
que a gente tá falando isso de usar a
base, usar as
informações, como que você, isso é um
assunto até ravelmente antigo, mas que
tem tido evoluções, como que vocês têm
lidado?
Acho que acho que a Fei vai poder falar
de unidade e o Luciano vai poder falar
talvez de boas práticas que ele tem
visto no mercado sobre a segurança da
informação, a preocupação das lideranças
em putz, será que eu deixo minha equipe
inteira subir essa base aqui num LLM?
Será que vão usar os dados? Será que não
vão usar? Eh, enfim, tem todo esse essa
preocupação. Tem empresas que ainda não
permitem a a os colaboradores usarem
inteligência especial. Aí eu conheço
gente que que pega o computador pessoal
para poder usar, para poder ter mais
produtividade, né? A pessoa fazendo um
hack ali. Como que vocês têm visto isso
no mercado? Acho que dá para começar
pela pela talvez contar um pouco o caso
de uso ali da BEV e o Luciano um olhar
mais amplo.
Cara, eu acho que
inicialmente, né, tinha muita
resistência do negócio. Isso ainda vai
ter em algumas áreas. Isso é inevitável,
tá?
Eh, a gente começou com uma linha
de habilitar ferramentas. Então,
pegaram, né, o IPI do chat GPT,
criaram GPT pra gente. Eh, e aí isso fez
o time começar a experimentar, né? Isso,
putz, feito pelo tipo de tecnologia com
infraegurança, tal, em relação a
dados. O que a gente
percebeu ao longo do tempo é que as
ferramentas, tipo, o que que o GMI
evolui, o que que eh o GPT evolui, o
Antropic evolui com cloud, é muito mais
rápido do que o que a gente vai
conseguir fazer internamente, né? Por
mais que a gente já vamos usar e criar o
nosso, não tem como, não é o nosso core
business, né?
E e aí a partir daí começou um
movimento, né, acho
que
de em como que a gente libera essas
ferramentas e não é um processo fácil,
porque é uma empresa grande, né? Então
não é um processo simples. Então a gente
começou com algumas
ferramentas passando por cyber source,
por legal para testar, pra gente testar,
pro nosso time ganhar produtividade,
porque também só vale comprar a briga de
putz, eu quero essa ferramenta se eu
tiver certeza de que o time, cara,
ganhou produtividade com isso. Então a
gente começou assim, essa essa história
um pouco de AI e tudo mais, a gente tá
nessa jornada tem um pouco mais de um
ano. eh, nesse vai e volta com cyber,
com legal, tentando
entender. E aí, a partir do momento que
a gente começou a testar e começou a ter
os cases reais, né, dos ganhos, foi mais
fácil negociar a liberação de algumas
ferramentas, né? E a gente segue fazendo
isso. Então, a gente tem algumas
ferramentas que já tão aprovadas,
inclusive de criação de agentes. A gente
tá com a Criai já aprovada e começando a
criar agên um pouco mais de escala. Eh,
e ao mesmo tempo a gente tem
eh, tá olhando paraa primeira para
liberar o Raplit pro time de produto e
design criar MVP eh sem necessidade
tanto de interação de engenharia, né?
Então tem um time pequeno usando, putz,
uma vez que isso entregou valor, que viu
que tem que importante, que putz, faz
sentido, aí a gente passa para uma
segunda instância que é uma contratação
mais enterprise. Mas uma das coisas
também as ferramentas evoluíram muito no
enterprise em termos de
segurança. Eh, se você for negociar com
os principais hoje, eles já têm soluções
de enterprise que deixam a empresa muito
mais segura em relação a dados. seus
dados não vão eh pro para treinar o
modelo. Você você tem vários acordos que
já permitem que você tenha mais
segurança na sua empresa. Acho que o
Luciano vai saber até muito mais do que
eu sobre isso, mas isso foi também
criando
uma uma educação sobre os pros outros
times, né? Porque esse essa questão ela
o nosso time é empolgado para usar, mas
o o time de cyber ele não quer que a
gente use porque isso vão ter n riscos.
Então a gente foi estabelecendo
protocolos de necessários de segurança,
isso foi evoluindo. Então a etapa que a
gente tá é, a gente tem um tool kit
liberado já que galera pode usar. Tem
outras ferramentas que às vezes alguém
fala: "Ah, eu quero usar o cursor, por
exemplo, tá liberado também". Então ele
já tá em escala com time de engenharia.
Então eh isso fez com que a gente
olhasse, tá bom? Essas ferramentas aqui,
sucesso, funcionou, passou em todos os
requisitos de cyber e legal. Boto para
todo mundo. Essa ferramenta a gente não
sabe nem se a gente vai querer usar no
futuro. Pega 10, 15 pessoas, coloca para
usar, entendeu? Que entregou valor, aí
tem que passar para uma nova etapa com
cyber aqui. Mas exige paciência. Sim, é
um vai e volta eh que você vai ter que
fazer.
Sim, verdade, verdade, Fernanda. Eu acho
isso isso é uma das coisas assim eh
legais no sentido assim de interessantes
pela variação do desafio, mas é
interessante assim pegar o o a própria
experiência da Fernanda e comparando
com, por exemplo, a experiência que eu
tenho no Google como desenvolvedor
dentro do Google, eh as preocupações são
completamente diferentes. Então, a gente
tem uma facilitação muito maior de usar
as ferramentas que são mais suitch de
escritório, eh otimização de de sprint,
eh análise de jornada de produto e tem
uma peneira muito mais rígida para as
ferramentas de automação de trabalho de
desenvolvedor. Mas assim, é entendível
por quê? Porque o produto é o produto
raro, o produto de valor do Google é o
código. Então o a maior a maior a maior
preocupação e até sem nenhuma má
intenção assim, eu tô eu estava
utilizando o cursor e assim nada contra
o cursor, pode ser o cursor wind surf, o
o copilot do KitHub e sem querer tá
usando uma base de código, mesmo com
todos os contratos de privacidade, de
não compartilhamento de dados, usar uma
base de produto, uma base de código que
por conceito não é para sair da empresa,
alguma coisa que ainda tá confidencial,
alguma uma versão nova de produto que
não tá pública. Então eu acho que parte
do desafio aí, voltando assim pra visão
dos líderes, é exatamente encontrar esse
meio do caminho onde você tá habilitando
as pessoas a praticarem a criatividade
nos processos. Eh, como como achei muito
legal que a Fernanda comentou, que a
ideia dos gêmeos digitais de clientes
veio do próprio time que tem um
problema. Isso é sensacional, assim,
isso é uma cultura assim de de inovação,
experimentação sensacional, mas o líder
tem que ser aquela pessoa que tá sempre
de olho também se a água não tá subindo
muito e não vai alar a casa, entendeu?
Assim, tem que ter o meio termo do vamos
experimentar tudo, experimentar tudo não
vai ser legal, mas também ser restrito
demais não vai ser legal. Aí entre o
feeling do do líder aí assim, não
querendo jogar muitas coisas na costa do
líder, mas com a responsabilidade do
líder. primeiro entender o que que as
outras empresas estão sendo bem
sucedidas no mercado. Eu não preciso
necessariamente assinar o GMI, assinar o
chat PD para começar a ver um resultado.
Eu posso entender o que que mesmo a
minha empresa pode ser uma software
house, mas o que que os bancos estão
tendo de benefício é um business. O que
que as seguradoras estão tendo de
benefício é outro business. e começar a
tentar refletir como que isso cai na
minha realidade. Putz, se isso funcionou
para uma seguradora numa análise de
crédito e numa análise de contrato, isso
vai me ajudar com as minhas análises de
contrato também. Se isso ajudou um banco
a ficar compliance com com uma
legislação ou uma lei que é muito mais
restrita do que é o que eu tendo que
seguir, putz, eu posso pegar essa
experiência e talvez diminuir alguns
acessórios e adotar isso para mim
também. Então, talvez eu acho que o
papel do líder é meio também trazer essa
visão do do da arte do possível, vamos
falar assim, do que que já tá
acontecendo e que assim não dá para ter
certeza se vai nos ajudar também, mas
pelo menos é um caminho que alguém já
andou que dá pra gente experimentar.
Perfeito, perfeito. Eu queria, eu
queria puxar duas perguntas aqui, aliás,
antes de puxar duas da audiência, tenho
uma para fazer para vocês. Essa eu acho
que é mais rápida de responder, mas se
um líder quisesse começar
amanhã esse movimento de A, qual vocês
acham que devia ser o primeiro passo
para ele fazer?
Porque, e aí eu quero falar só porque eu
quero, eu tô fazendo essa pergunta que
tem um comentário aqui do Felipe, eu já
vi esse comentário em vários lugares da
situação. A gente na PM3 a gente fala
com muita empresa a situação em muitos
lugares liberaram na minha empresa e
piorou porque as pessoas não estão
validando o que aí a
gera e aí estão tá causando retrabalho.
E aí eu vejo outros líderes vendo isso
falar: "Não vou liberar para ninguém
porque, né, o pessoal não sabe usar".
Enfim, e aí gera esse mecanismo de
autodefesa, por qualquer que seja de
motivo, gera esse mecanismo de
autodefesa. Então, para quem quer
começar, quem quer escalar isso,
acelerar na sua empresa, qual seria o
primeiro passo? Ó, eu eu primeiro diria
para quem quer começar a usar na vida
pessoal de forma muito estruturada e
escalável, tá? Tipo, eu tenho um
específico para cada filho para eles
estudarem para troca. E afinal, e um
deles funcionou muito bem. Os meninos
nunca tiraram nota tão boa. Menino só
tir nove, as coisas que não tiravam
nove. Não achei que fosse funcionar, mas
é um específico que sabe a limitação de
cada um e que sabe, tipo, um gosta de
basquete, então ele faz eh tudo, ele
conecta com basquete, então ele
conseguiu entender muito mais. Então,
primeiro utilizem na sua vida, encontrem
coisas na sua vida, porque isso vai
fazer você entender o mecanismo de como
funciona, né, para você explorar.
E aí, eh, quando você vai pro mundo
empresa, eh, também não dá, assim, eu
acho que tudo começa pelo exemplo, né?
Eu não posso pegar uma coisa que sai do
GPT, eu nem li, e vou colar e vou mandar
paraas pessoas. Não vou fazer isso.
Aliás, você, bom uso é você ter uma boa
discussão com o GPT em cima do resultado
que ele trouxe. Às vezes piora, você
volta para cima e fala: "Não é nada
disso, vamos voltar aqui". Eh, mas é
você entender esse mecanismo que, cara,
a o modelo LLM, ele é
alguém, vamos, não vou, não gosto de
personificar a EAI, porque isso vira uma
outra discussão, mas é um modelo que ele
vai te responder baseado no que ele tem
de conhecimento, que é justamente o que
o Luciano falou, assim, o maior valor
não tá no LLM. O LM ele é commodity, se
a gente for pensar, tem vários LLMs que
a gente pode usar. O que diferencia é o
quanto você, com seu conhecimento
potencializa com
Llm pode acontecer, pode acontecer na
empresa, mas ao mesmo
tempo, no médio prazo, quem tiver
fazendo isso também não vai ser bem
visto, né? simplesmente tacando o
resultado direto sem avaliar sobre, que
é exatamente a mesma coisa. Eu tenho, eu
tenho uma dúvida, eu pergunto pro
Marcel, Marcelo respondeu: "Eu sou um
papagaio, só repliquei, tipo, não fiz um
aprofundamento sobre aquilo. Você também
não vai ser bem visto em relação a
isso."
Então, é um ajuste natural que vai
acontecer, sabe? Eu acho que às vezes a
gente também coloca muita expectativa
que a gente tá num momento de mudança e
nossa, vai mudar e vai ser tudo
perfeito, não vai acontecer, não vai
acontecer. o próprio o próprio mercado
ele se ajusta, as próprias pessoas elas
vão se ajustando àquela
mudança. É, é isso, é isso, Fernando.
Talvez, eu acho que esse seja um
momento muito desconfortável pros
líderes que ainda acreditam na liderança
monocrática,
porque um um dos pontos que eu vejo
assim, das conversas que eu tenho com
clientes do Google e tudo mais, que
acabam sendo um caminho menos turbulento
para você começar a adotar, e isso eu
tenho tido conversa com unicórnios, com
bancos, com empresas familiares e assim,
é uma dor comum, dependendo da estrutura
do time que você tá andando.
é exatamente o seu ponto de por onde
começar. E normalmente as empresas que
dependem mais daquele líder messiânico
que só ele decide a direção que o time
vai, o melhor caminho, essas empresas
têm mais dificuldade para conseguir dar
um próximo passe. Por quê? Porque o
caminho mais fácil aí assim falando
tecnicamente agora, abstraindo um pouco
os desafios de negócio de produto, o
caminho mais fácil para você conseguir
adotar e começar a diminuir os medos é
você pegar uma jornada que você conhece
bem de ponto a ponta, que o time tá
ajudando você a entender quais são as
dores que essa jornada tem, aonde que tá
levando mais tempo, aonde que tá
faltando dado, aonde que o resultado não
tá tão confiável. E isso vira um
protótipo de experimentação de ar. Você
não vai simplesmente liberar o chat
eptou o dimin para todo mundo da empresa
de uma vez, para quem faz campanha de
marketing, para quem tá em PID, para
quem cada time tem o seu desafio, tem o
seu momento, tem os seus riscos. Então,
primeiro você faz um experimento
controlado. Desse experimento
controlado, você como líder consegue
enxergar quais que foram as dores da
adoção, as políticas de segurança da
empresa facilitaram, atrapalharam, tem
algum risco de dado que a gente não tá
enxergando muito bem. Depois da adoção,
a performance do time ficou pelo menos
igual, que assim, a única coisa ruim é
piorar. Se ficar pelo menos igual com
uma ferramenta mais organizada, mais
automatizada, já é uma vitória. Então,
tentar baixar um pouco a bola das
expectativas que você tem de, ah, tem
que diminuir pela metade o custo, tem
que aumentar a eficiência no dobro,
assim, são metas assim muito audaciosas
pro
experimento. E uma vez que você rodou
esse experimento, entra um processo de
liderança, de reconhecer essas pessoas,
essas pessoas podem virar os seus
embaixadores da empresa. Olha, eles
foram os precursores, eles conseguiram
fazer, eles começam a propagar essas
ideias para outros times e você consegue
ir espalhando a ideia de uma forma mais
orgânica, que é o oposto da monocracia,
né? chega o o diretor, o presidente,
manda aquele e-mail lá para todo mundo
da empresa, olha, a partir de
segunda-feira todo mundo tem acesso e
todo mundo, eu já vi isso acontecer e
assim é muito, muito assustador. E no
próximo mês a gente vai ter um desafio
interno na empresa, que todas as pessoas
têm que sugerir uma melhoria que a gente
pode ter com IA. Putz, assim, eu acho
que isso é um caminho muito, muito
perigoso que cai na questão que o
camarada falou aí, que começa a virar
uma bagunça e começa a piorar as coisas
e desaceleram esse processo de evolução
ao invés de ajudar, né?
Perfeito. Perfeito. Exatamente. E e eu
acho que em todo o processo de grande
evolução, grande revolução, isso
acontece. Isso, esse vai e volta, esses
medos, esses mecanismos de defesa, seja
proposital ou não, acontece, é normal, é
um efeito natural disso tudo. Eh, e é e
é o que a gente vai viver, a gente vai
ter que saber lidar mesmo, tanto como
líderes quanto como pessoas. Isso que eu
gostei muito do que a Fe falou do uso no
dia a dia. Eu comecei a usar LMs assim
ali em 2000 e na época da Copa 2022 eu
acho que foi, mas eu comecei a realmente
usar no meu dia a dia como quase um
copiloto nos últimos meses, até porque a
o nível de qualidade avançou
drasticamente. Antes era brincadeirinha,
agora você consegue ela ter memória, ela
consegue ver coisas que não dava para
fazer antes.
E meu dia a dia, não só a vida pessoal,
mas do trabalho também mudou muito. Eu
queria fechar, tem duas perguntas do
Márcio que eu gostei bastante e são duas
porque uma é direcionada pro Luciano e
uma é para F. Eu vou começar aqui pela
pela
Luciano. Eh, o Márcio pergunta:
"Luciano, uma dúvida do que a Fernanda
falou. Tendo a evolução empresarial do
Gemini, entendemos que nossos prompts e
documentos não são usados para
treinamento da IA, mas essa evolução é
contínua e a evolução continua, acho que
é isso, na verdade, a pelo eu imagino
que a evolução do modelo, né? O modelo
continua ficando melhor. É, eu acho que
é uma excelente pergunta. Eu acho que
vale até ressaltar, especialmente pra
galera que tá começando a experimentar,
e assim, isso não é algo único do
Gemini. O Jaminai tem isso também, mas
as outros modelos têm algo parecido que
é a questão do uso
gratuito. A gente tem que tomar muito
cuidado que assim, uma barreira de
entrada muito baixa é a gente pegar o
nosso Gmail, no caso do Gemini ou criar
nossa conta gratuita na Tropic ou na
Open Ai, aonde for, porque os modelos tm
o que a gente chama de freeer, que é o
uso gratuito diário que você tem tantas
chamadas ou tantas requisições, alguma
coisa assim.
Mas o tradeoff desse uso gratuito, e
isso vai est nos termos de serviço,
assim, não é nada escondido, não é nada
roubado de vocês, eh, é que você tá
concordando que as suas interações com o
modelo podem ser usadas pela pela
empresa dona do produto para otimizar o
produto. O que que isso significa? Isso
significa que se eu tô usando o Gini com
meu Gmail, que eu tenho acesso gratuito
a usar os modelos mais novos, mas eu tô
usando eh as propostas de negócio da
minha empresa, eu tô fazendo análise de
código com código que não é público, tem
a chance de uma informação que não é
pública acabar se tornando pública pelo
meu mau uso. Existe assim um caso muito
muito emblemático logo das primeiras
versões do chat GPT que foi com a
Imraer, se eu não tô enganado, ou com
General Elétic, General Elétric, onde
eles tiveram uma torção muito cedo do
dos modelos e assim não é culpa do chat
GPT, não é culpa da plataforma. Eh, eles
tiveram uma doação muito rápida e talvez
eles não tiveram esse cuidado com a
parte de gestão de dados e o time de PID
da empresa começou a utilizar com os
seus documentos e os seus projetos e e
houve parte de vazamento dessas
informações porque pelo uso gratuito
essas informações foram reusadas. E a
partir desse ponto, quem fez perguntas
relacionadas ao nicho desse desses
projetos, acabaram tendo informações
desses projetos também. Então o que que
eu quero dizer com isso? Não tô querendo
botar mais medo nas pessoas, mas isso
vale para qualquer produto que a gente
começa a usar. Isso não vale só para as
LLMs. É importante a gente entender,
especialmente agora como no Brasil
finalmente que a gente tem uma lei de
proteção dos dados, é a gente entender
quais são as regras de utilização dos
dados. E meio que uma regra comum, isso
a gente pode meio manter como mantra. Se
a gente tá usando gratuito, muito
provavelmente os nossos dados podem ser
reusados. Então, mantém isso sempre na
cabeça. E isso é importante porque eu
vou deixar de usar o gratuito porque
meus dados podem estar sendo
compartilhados de forma alguma. O que eu
tenho que fazer é ser cuidadoso com o
tipo de dado que eu tô usando. Por
exemplo, se eu tenho, eu não trabalho no
Google, eu tenho, eu sou um funcionário,
sou analista de dados no Marcel na CM3.
Eu tenho os meus desafios de otimização
de processamento de contrato, extração
de informação, enriquecimento de data
leak, enfim, um cenário de dados
convencional. Eu tô experimentando com
Gemini, que ainda tô querendo convencer
o Marcel a pena a gente ter um contrato
Enterprise com o Google para usar o
Gemini ou não. Eu quero praticar análise
de contrato. Hoje, felizmente, a gente
tá num momento bom que existe muitos
dados públicos que são muitos
semelhantes aos dados ou pelo menos em
estrutura que a gente usa de forma
privada. Então você vai encontrar
dataset de contrato, você vai encontrar
dataset de exames, você vai encontrar
dataset de decisão jurídica,
virtualmente falando qualquer cenário
que você imaginar, você vai ter dados de
exemplo para você utilizar. Então, no
gratuito, você exercita com que não é
arriscado, com que já é público, com
quem já tá disponível em alguma
biblioteca pública, ou no Google
Datasets ou no Kegle, ou nos exemplos da
WS, enfim, a plataforma que vocês
imaginarem. E toma cuidado com o que é
confidencial. A gente não pode esquecer,
a gente não pode deixar de olhar o label
dos nossos arquivos. O que é sensível, o
que é confidencial, o que é privado, não
pode sair da empresa. Não importa se é
com Gemini, não importa se é no e-mail,
não pode sair. A gente não pode perder
essas preocupações de dados pela ânsia
que a gente tem de usar uma ferramenta
nova.
Perfeito. Muito, muito legal. É, e eu
concordo com você,
Luciano. Uma parte que você falou que
isso não é só para LLMs, é isso mesmo.
É, tem informação trafegando em tudo que
é lugar. Exatamente. Tudo que é lugar.
Eh, F, pergunta também no máximo, mas
achei bem legal. Ele, você falou que
criou
seus custom GPTs, etc. Ele perguntou se
essa ferramenta tá liberada pra empresa,
se tá dentro do compliance, como foi
essa essa parte. Eu criei GPTs para mim
inicialmente, tá? Eu comecei criando um
GPT que imitava o Milton Cunha, gente,
nas coisas que eu queria
escrever. Eh, e aí eu fui entendendo
que, cara, eu consigo ter um GPT que eu
consiga estudar sobre AI com esse GPT.
Eu consigo ter um GPT que é sabe muito
de produto, então subir várias coisas
técnicas de produto e design dentro
desse dentro desse GPT que eu gostaria
que fosse, né, o o VP de produto. Então
tudo isso que foi o que o Luciano falou,
eram informações que eram públicas, que
não tinham a ver com informações da
empresa. Então os GPTs eles foram
criados, né, quando eu comecei a criar,
que era na minha conta pessoal, paga,
mas pessoal, eles eram para problemas
específicos. Hoje em dia a gente tem já,
né, eh, dentro da empresa, eh, liberado
algumas ferramentas e aí isso acontece.
A gente tem o cloud e eu uso os projetos
dentro do cloud mais ou menos paraa
mesma função que o GPT, porque aí eu
consigo subir eh informações que são
mais confidenciais e que eu que eu não
subiria a no meu GPT. Então, no final é
sobre bom senso, né? Você pode usar o
GPT para criar os seus para uma série de
coisas que não vão ter informações
confidenciais, mas que vão ajudar no seu
dia a dia e usar ferramentas internas
para subir as informações que te são eh
que te são mais sensíveis, né? E aí você
usar as ferramentas internas. Então essa
é a forma que eu equilibrei o meu tool
kit. Então, por exemplo, formação de
estratégia de produto, etc.
tá dentro do código, porque é o que a
gente tá usando hoje. Informações minhas
sobre dúvidas de produto, discussão de
produto ou quando eu vou fazer benchmark
do mercado, olhar outros competidores,
eu eu faço nos nos GPTS mesmo.
Legal, gente.
Infelizmente a gente já tá chegando ao
final. Deu aqui uma hora já de conteúdo.
Foi muito, muito legal. Acho que deu
para trocar uma ideia do nível de
liderança, do nível de tático execução,
como lidar com time, como lidar com
medo, inclusive dicas paraa criança
estudar também. Gostei dessa da P, muito
legal. Queria super agradecer, Fernanda,
Luciano, super agradecer, foi muito
rico. Espero que quem esteja com a gente
no chat tenha gostado também. Muito
legal, gente. Super obrigado.
Opa, estamos junto. Muito prazer lhe
conhecer, Fernanda. Muito prazer trocar
mais uma ideia com você. Marcel, conta
comigo. Estamos juntto demais. Eh,
deixei no chat aqui o meu meu link, se
alguém quiser trocar uma ideia. Bom, não
consegui deixar o linkedinho, o chat não
deixa. É, vou vou reclamar no YouTube,
não consigo compartilhar mesmo. Ah,
caramba. Eu acho que eu consigo mandar.
Acho que eu consigo mandar aqui. Vou
puxar seu link de mando. Pode deixar.
Vou vou vou colar no chat privado aqui
para você para ajudar. Não, já, mas
fiquem super à vontade aí se vocês
quiserem trocar uma ideia, tiver alguma
dúvida. E a minha missão agora é
apresentar os games do Gemini para ver
se a Fernanda gosta tanto quanto do
GPTs. Bora,
muito bom. Obrigado, gente, pelo papo. E
Luciano, bora continuar essa conversa
aí para mudar de plataforma.
Boa. Legal, gente, muito obrigado. Mas
eu queria também falar para quem tá no
chat continuar aqui, porque a
gente tem uma
capacitação totalmente customizada pro
seu time, paraa sua empresa, pro que
você precisa. De acordo com a solidade
das pessoas, a gente já capacitou
líderes, né, Silves, VPs, heads em a e
em gestão de produto e às vezes muitas
vezes na mestra das duas coisas, assim
como a gente já capacitou, analistas,
gerentes, coordenadores, então são
níveis diferentes de profundidade de
acordo com a sua necessidade. E a gente
pode capacetar tanto com cursos gravados
na nossa plataforma, quanto também com
cursos ao vivo online, quanto também com
cursos presenciais. a gente monta uma
trilha de acordo com o seu nível de
maturidade, de acordo com a sua
necessidade na sua empresa. Se você é
líder e tá sentindo que precisa de algo
assim, escaneia aqui o QR code ou acessa
o link que a gente tá enviando no chat.
E se você é um liderado e acha que a sua
empresa pode usufruir disso, aproveita
também, compartilha esse link com a sua
liderança. Aliás, compartilha a live com
essa liderança que acho que os
aprendizados foram incríveis. Pena que
foi só uma hora que tem muito assunto
legal. E você pode, se você quer
aproveitar mais conteúdos como esse,
assine o nosso canal aqui no YouTube,
porque toda semana sai episódio do mesa
de produto no COD a gente tem conversas
tão ricas quanto essa, assim como também
estão saindo agora vídeos no qual a
gente tenta discutir mais e abrir a
cabeça para temas e coisas que t
acontecido no dia a dia. Então você pode
estar sempre atualizado em discussões
ricas e profundas com a PM3. E se tiver
alunos aqui com a gente, tenho certeza
que vocês aproveitam muito a nossa
comunidade, que tem muita coisa rica,
muita discussão sempre tanto online
quanto presencial. Pessoal, super
obrigado. Desejo vocês todos uma boa
noite, um bom resto de semana e até
mais.
[Música]
[Aplausos]
เฮ เฮ